[Music]
last night wasn't exactly a ratings
party on Idol but its first live
elimination show came in a close second
up against the voice as
twenty-one-year-old contested Texas
native Cade Feiner won a spot in the top
10 and maybe Katy Perry's heart
Katy he called you sweetheart last real
[Applause]
[Music]
real is the flirting well I mean when
you're a star and you have that that
appeal that makes everybody flustered
it really works in your favor but with
the judge ever pull of Paula Abdul
remember one contestant claimed he and
Paula dated yes Katie's like that you're
spoken for right now yeah girl yeah wait
what did we just get a kaboom
confirmation is Katie back with her ex
Orlando Bloom I mean they did split in
February of 2017 after dating for a year
but last month she got flirty commenting
on his shirtless pose also a source did
tell et that the exes plan to give their
love a second chance
cut - Katy's recent Instagram Orlando
Bloom are you a mrs. Broome no I'm not a
mrs. Grove
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]